foreign
[Music]
Morrisons was supposed to be a dream
ticket for some of the biggest banks in
the world instead Goldman Sachs and
others ended up losing hundreds of
millions of pounds this is the story of
how the UK's largest leveraged buyout in
a decade turned into a nightmare on Wall
Street back in 2021 markets were booming
private Equity firms aided by low
interest rates and flushed with record
amounts of cash from their investors
we're targeting bigger and bigger
publicly listed companies to buy or take
private w m Morrison a beloved British
grocer that had been listed since the
1960s became a Target due to its
unencumbered property portfolio U.S
firms Clayton de bellier and rice and
Fortress soon found themselves in a
shootout for Morrisons while cdnr
prevailed with a 10 billion pound bid
this left its banks led by Goldman Sachs
on the hook for 6.6 billion pounds on
top of this Goldman contributed to 1.3
billion pounds of preference shares
risky debt-like instruments when it
comes to leverage buyouts Banks like
Goldman have a motto we're in the moving
business not the storage business this
is because they don't want to hold the
loans long term but pass them on to
funds that specialize in investing in
Risky debt
this is where the danger comes in
Imagine a company supplying milk to
supermarkets which buys it at a set
price from Farmers but then sells it at
a fluctuating market price to groceries
if the price of milk fell sharply the
supplier would take big losses it's the
same for debt in a leveraged buyout the
banks promised the borrower a maximum
interest rate if investors demand a
higher rate the banks fund the
difference and take a loss when
Morrisons was underwritten credit
markets were hot and the banks were more
complacent about their Risk by the time
they came to pass the parcel markets
were falling apart and investors were
unwilling to buy while Goldman and Co
managed to sell some chunks of the debt
bit by bit over the course of 2022
they've taken a hit worth hundreds of
millions of pounds in the process
foreign
[Music]